la gare de trappe a enfin eu droit à une
inauguration en bonne et du forme ce
mardi 28 mai les travaux étaiit terminé
depuis mi-décembre 2012 après 6 ans de
recherche de financement 1 million
d'euros investis puis 8 mois de travaux
l'accès principal et l'entrée secondaire
ont été rénové on a revu surtout la
sécurisation de cet accès en disposant
des grilles incorporé dans des dans des
dans des rouleaux on a aussi également
vu tout le dessin des des barrières et
des limites d'emprise pour en faire
quelque chose de plus aéré plus moderne
aussi l'éclairage a été entièrement revu
pour donner un côté plus chaleureux plus
accueillant ce gare la gare s'est aussi
dotée d'écran plat pour informer les
voyageurs des horaires ou des retards
des trains j'ai vu ici le changement et
ouais ça va c'est pas mal pas comment
expliquer là c'est vrai que c'est beau
quand même au niveau au niveau de
l'entrée c'est un peu plus accueillant
en fait donc c'est un site à prendre le
train et la g de Trapp c'est tellement
je sais pas c'est très vieux il y a il y
a pas de toilett il y a pas il y a pas
d'hygiène ce que on comprend pas c'est
il y a toujours pas de pour descendre
les escaliers si vous voulez il y a pas
pour les personnes handicapé des choses
comme ça actuellement trap ne fait pas
partie du schéma directeur
d'accessibilité qui fixe les travaux à
réaliser dans les
gares